[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGIO FELIX: Hello, everyone.
My name is Sergio Felix, and
I work as a study at Google.
SOEREN WALLS: And
I'm Soeren Walls.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
SERGIO FELIX: Thank you for
joining us on the migrating
a monolithic application
to microservices.
Also thank you for waiting
in line for such a long time.
This is the last leg of the day.
Hopefully, you
didn't fall asleep.
SOEREN WALLS: [LAUGHS]
Thanks for coming.
SERGIO FELIX: If you
have any questions,
we're going to have
a Dory available.
We'll try to mix live audience
questions with the Dory.
So just be aware that
that's available.
SOEREN WALLS: Get
used to the clickers.
Sergio and I both work in
an org at Google called
Cloud Engineering Productivity.
This means essentially
our job at Google
is to build tools to help make
other Googlers more productive.
Specifically, Sergio works
on a tool called Louhi,
and I work on something
called GlassPane.
SERGIO FELIX: To give
you a little more context
around this, Louhi is a
release orchestration tool.
It basically allows
developers-- but mostly
release engineers--
a way to automate
the process of managing,
scheduling, planning,
controlling, software builds
through different stages
and deployments.
Basically, you can think of
Louhi like most CI/CD tools
out there.
There's a concept of a
flow that has triggers,
and the triggers
kick off a pipeline
that has a bunch of steps.
And then you get notifications
when those steps move along.
And we use these
weird looking flows
to compile and build these
weird looking applications
that in our team, we
call hybrid applications.
These are applications are
made up from both open source
software and internal software
that gets bundled together,
build tested, and so on.
SOEREN WALLS: GlassPane,
on the other hand,
is an internal metrics
platform at Google
that's essentially designed
to help leaders understand
the health and relative
performance of their projects
and teams, through mainly
actionable insights.
So today, we want to tell
you a story about our journey
and how we migrated
both Louhi and GlassPane
from monolithic applications
and split them up
into microservices.
But first, why did we
decide to build though
Louhi and GlassPane
as monolithic apps
in the first place?
This allowed us to
experiment quickly.
We needed to focus
on the business logic
and having a single
binary really
allowed us to do this while
preventing initial overdesign.
We weren't as concerned
with everything
working as beautifully as
possible as long as it worked.
Since we were a small
team, we could also easily
manage the changes
just kind of by saying,
you work on this thing.
I'll work on this thing.
It also made the maintenance
around our binary pretty easy
because we only
had to do it once.
It was great until it wasn't.
Our teams were growing.
We started getting more
product requirements,
and we started onboarding
new team members.
We started to have too
much cognitive load.
When we brought a new
person onto the team,
instead of just needing to
understand the small piece they
were responsible for, they
had to spend a few weeks
to figure out how the whole
architecture of our application
worked.
We had to start
delaying deployments
to sync features across
the different team members,
and we had no way to
independently scale
certain small parts of
the app that might need
more resources than others.
We had to scale the
whole app all at once,
wasting tons of resources.
This made it really
messy to debug.
When an error happened, it
was really hard to go and find
the root cause.
We started to feel like we had
built a cage around ourselves
that we were
desperate to escape,
and this is where
microservices came in.
SERGIO FELIX: But what is
a microservice and what
do they even come from?
Before we go deep into
patterns and all that,
we want to take a
step back and just
look at the history of
where microservices actually
come from.
You will know about my
own monolithic apps.
We have a single binary
that gets deployed.
Changing one of its internal
services, as someone mentioned,
requires the deployment
of the whole application.
So that's a slow
velocity to production.
And then a Soeren mentioned,
new engineers arrive,
and they have to understand
these really complex
applications with
a large codebase.
And they usually have
to submit PR requests.
And there's a central
group of people, hopefully,
who have the authority
to approve those changes.
Again, this is slow.
They also have a single database
where all the modules inside
talk to the database.
The industry then moved on to
service oriented architecture.
The term was coined around 1998
by a group of people working
on something called
[? coreby. ?]
Those old enough might
be able to remember.
And the idea here was that
you would build services
a bit more decoupled then
[? in the ?] monolithic app.
And you had four types
of business layer
at the top, a bunch of
enterprise services,
and at the bottom, application
infrastructure services-- all
tied together with this thing
called the enterprise service
bus.
Around that time, we
wanted to share everything,
and so we had a single
database that was
shared across all the services.
The problem with
this is that if you
made a change to your database,
that change could ripple
throughout all your services.
That was a problem.
Also the enterprise
service was needed
to scale depending on how
many services you had,
and there was a single
point of failure.
Then things evolve a little bit,
and we got to microservices.
Here autonomous
teams are organized
over a single functionality.
Microservices are
independently deployable,
and teams produce
and consume APIs.
This makes it really
simple for other services
to scale really fast, and
it enables innovation.
Also, nowadays, microservices
are deploying containers,
so that it gets even
simpler to deploy.
SOEREN WALLS: So what are the
benefits of microservices?
Well, they're pretty
simple to understand.
These small services make it
so that onboarding new team
members is relatively easy when
compared to a monolithic app
because people are only
focused on the things
that they're responsible for.
It also allows you to work
on potentially different tech
stacks within your team.
You might have someone
working on Python
for this microservice,
someone working
with Java for the other one--
pretty cool.
They also have isolated
responsibility,
which means that all
the microservices are
responsible for a
single thing, and you
can deploy them independently.
They're also scalable
and distributable,
and you can reuse business logic
throughout your application
simply by making a call
to a microservice that's
responsible for the certain
functionality that you need.
They're also really
fault tolerant.
Later, we'll talk
about some patterns
you can use the circuit
breaker pattern to handle
when a service goes down.
This is something that's
not quite as elegantly
possible with monolithic apps.
OK, those are some
of the benefits
but how do I actually go about
migrating a monolithic app?
This is something that's really
daunting for a lot of teams.
You might have a
bunch of legacy code.
You might have all these
different dependencies that
are intermixed, and
you're wondering, OK, how
do I go about tackling this?
Well, with both
Louhi and GlassPane,
we had a monolithic
app that we wanted
to break into microservices,
but we weren't sure how.
We initially asked ourselves
these questions, which you also
might be wondering.
How big should these
services even be?
And how do I actually go about
splitting up the functionality
in my monolithic app?
Well, the micro part
of microservices--
it's kind of more of a
label than a description.
The size of a microservice
can really vary.
There's this concept called
service granularity that's
essentially how big
are your microservices,
and there's no one size
fits all approach for this.
It's going to depend on your
infrastructure and your tech
stack.
Ask yourself how much
overhead is associated
with building a new service.
Consider things like source
control management, deployment,
testing, et cetera.
Later, we'll talk
about some tools
that you can use to
automate these things.
Ask yourself, does
creating a service cost
more than implementing
its functionality?
If that's the case,
that's a good indication
your service might be too small.
One approach that's
commonly used
is domain driven
design, which emphasizes
the idea of bounded
contexts where
each component of
your application--
or in this case,
each microservice--
is only responsible
for a single thing.
If you're familiar with
object oriented design,
you can think of this as each
microservice handling one
strong entity and
its related business
logic in the data layer.
Beware of an anti pattern
called nano services.
This is essentially when your
services are so small that it's
not feasible to maintain them.
To give you an example
of this, we actually
ran into this problem
with GlassPane.
So it started as a monolithic
app running an App Engine.
And after a design
process, we decided
that there were essentially
seven domains in GlassPane.
So we created seven
microservices.
That was our magic number-ish.
We moved from the
monolithic app first
to this core micro
service that talks
to six other
microservices that handle
their respective domains.
And where we went
a little too small,
a little awry is when
we started making
an individual microservice
for every single metric
that we wanted to
show in GlassPane.
Now we wanted to show hundreds
of metrics in GlassPane,
so with that
infrastructure, we would
have to build hundreds of
different microservices
and do all of their release
and testing and logging
and all of the things
associated with each of those,
along with the complicated
data logic and business logic
that we might have.
Instead, we took a step back.
We said, OK, this is
not feasible for a team
size and our tech stack.
We decided we'll have a single
microservice responsible
for all the metrics.
But how do we keep that isolated
responsibility principle?
Well, having a
single microservice
allowed us to only have
release and tests and logging
for a single one.
So it solved that problem.
But we were able to take
advantage of Google Cloud
Functions, which provided
that isolated responsibility
without all of the
maintenance that goes along
with those separate services.
So this was our solution.
And maybe something
similar could work for you.
All right, I just
talked about deciding
on the size of
your microservices.
But how do you actually go about
splitting up the functionality
in your monolithic app?
There's a pattern for this
called the Strangler pattern.
It gets its name from the
Strangler vines of the fig
tree, which start at the top
of the tree in the leaves,
and they slowly work their way
down over years potentially
until they're
rooted in the soil.
And they've entirely consumed
the tree, and it dies.
You can think about
migrating your monolithic app
kind of like that--
slowly and creepily and
hopefully not in a forest.
So to give you an
example, here's
a monolithic
application we've got.
It's a single binary.
It's got some
modules in it-- maybe
the accounting module, the
shipping module, the inventory
module, and they're
all communicating
with the same database.
And when a user makes a
request, the monolithic app
is the only service
that handles it.
With the Strangler
pattern, the first step
to migrating this monolithic
app into microservices
is to add something
called a proxy.
Initially, all it's going
to do is reroute requests
that are coming from your
user to the monolithic app.
Nothing has changed about the
way your user is interacting
with the app.
This is just a
layer you've setup
so that you can begin
redirecting traffic
to new services as
you implement them.
Next let's say we want to
tackle the functionality that's
provided related to inventories
in our monolithic app.
We've decided that's a
domain that we want to put
into its own microservice.
So we create a separate
microservice binary
that we call the
inventory microservice.
And notice that it has its
own dedicated database.
This is crucial.
Microservices are not
really microservices
unless the data
layers are separate.
We haven't begun implementing
the functionality yet.
We just created a binary.
The next step is
to set up a link
between the proxy and that
new binary that's running.
As we implement the
functionality related
to inventory, we can
begin using the proxy
to redirect some of the
traffic into that new inventory
microservice binary.
Once we're done implementing
the functionality,
we can remove that
functionality from
the monolithic application.
Next, we tackle the next domain.
Let's say we want to
tackle the shipping logic.
So we create a new binary--
again, with its own database--
setup a link from the proxy to
that new microservice binary,
then as we implement the
functionality of the shipping
microservice, all the
traffic gets redirected.
And we can remove
that functionality
from our monolithic application.
We do the same thing for
the remaining modules--
create a new binary, we get up
with the proxy, implement it.
And now all of the
functionality is
gone from our monolithic app.
And voila, you're in
microservices-- great.
SERGIO FELIX: For
Louhi, fortunately,
we started with something
a lot more simpler--
our initial monolithic
application that
was built with Python 2.5,
and it was running with Flask.
And because the way we
architected, sorry, our modules
to begin with, we could easily
translate basically each module
into a service in
our new architecture.
So for the most part,
that was pretty easy.
However, not all the
modules were simple.
We had this pipeline
module, which
was kind of like a monster,
like a Frankenstein.
It did a bunch of things.
It stored the pipeline
configuration.
It managed the states
of the pipelines.
It managed a catalog
of stage types
and then also
contained all the logic
to actually run the pipeline.
So when we were
looking at this and we
wanted to transform this
module into microservices,
we decided to split this module
into three microservices.
The pipeline
service just managed
the state and the configuration
of the pipeline, and that's it.
And we had a
separate service that
just managed a catalog
of stage types,
and all the logic necessary
to run the actual stages
were in the GCB executor--
pretty simple.
SOEREN WALLS: All right,
so where to get started?
Well, source code and
documentation-- good
place to start.
Design docs are going
to be your best friends.
Create a strategy
for how you're going
to migrate from a monolithic
app into microservices.
It can be a costly
refactoring process
that you might have to delay
feature development for a while
or take some resources from
other parts of your team to do.
You want to create a design for
your final architecture, what
you want it to look like.
Decide on those domains
that your application
needs to handle.
This is actually
a cool opportunity
to maybe rethink some
of the things that
maybe weren't so pretty or
good about your initial app.
In Louhi and GlassPane, we
also created design docs
for each individual
microservice.
This made it really clear
what the entities were
that were being handled
by each microservice,
the business logic
related to them,
the data layers, and more
importantly, the contracts that
were being established
between each microservice
and the other services
that it needed a consume
or that needed to consume it.
Next ask yourself, do you want
to split up your source code
repository?
In GlassPane and Louhi,
we decided to do this.
By splitting our repository
into a single repository
per micro service,
we established
clear dependency relationships
between the services.
This is a really cool
thing about microservices
to take advantage of.
This also meant that,
essentially, there
is no other choice but to
deploy them separately,
which is it's one of the
key benefits to get out.
Finally, set team
responsibilities.
If you're a small
team, you might
have one member
who's responsible
for multiple microservices.
If you're a large
team, you might
have whole sub teams dedicated
to a single microservice.
Decide on this and
you'll be good to go.
You might be
wondering, OK, if I've
got a separate repository for
every microservice-- like here
in GlassPane, you can
see we had a repository
for the core service, the
preference service, the team
service, and so on.
How do I share
code between them?
Our solution was to add
a common repository.
It's not a microservice.
It's just a separate
repository where
we can put shared code that all
the individual microservices
can depend on.
This means we can still deploy
them separately and test them
separately, and they're not
depending on each other.
SERGIO FELIX: OK, so we
thought about the sizes
of the services.
We have our documents
set up in place.
And then for us in Louhi and
in GlassPane, we were thinking,
we want to move
to microservices.
What technology
stack do we pick?
So you can run microservices
in multiple ways.
You can run them as App
Engine applications,
as a customized Compute
Engine, in Kubernetes,
in Cloud Functions, in K native.
It depends.
For us, specifically,
we picked GKE mainly
because we could deploy a wide
variety of applications in GKE.
If you can put it
in a container,
you can probably run it.
We were also super interested
in self-healing capabilities
and the auto scaling
capabilities in GKE.
This meant our application would
be up and running all the time.
Also we really liked the
declared configuration in GKE.
We could just basically
tell GKE what we wanted,
and GKE will get it done.
Also we really like that in
GKE, we had easy network setup,
and GKE basically handled
the updates of our Kubernetes
cluster for us.
So we didn't have to
manually scheduled this
and run it for ourselves.
Plus since our old application
already leveraged most
of the GCP services,
we were also interested
because GKE can leverage things
like Stackdriver, Pub/Sub,
Datastore, and so on.
For the back end, though,
as our team changed,
we were more experts
on Java than in Python,
and so we picked Spring.
Mainly because we knew Java.
Our developers knew Spring.
It's a perfect fit.
Spring is a very
mature framework
used throughout the industry.
It's open source, cloud native.
It's as flexible as
you want it to be.
If you want to, you
can specifically
configure something or let
Spring auto configure itself.
Also there's tons
of documentation.
It was really easy
to get started.
On top of that, we
found that there
are these two projects, Spring
Cloud GCP and Spring Cloud
Kubernetes.
The first project basically
allows your Springboard
application to leverage
things like Pub/Sub, DataStore
authentication, and
so on really easily.
And Spring Cloud
Kubernetes allowed
the Springboard binaries
running on a GKE cluster
to leverage the Kubernetes API.
We'll talk about how we
use both of these things
in other slides.
SOEREN WALLS: Both
GlassPane pane and Louhi
use this front end
framework called
Polymer for our front end UI.
You might be wondering, why
am I talking about a front end
framework in a presentation
about microservices?
Well, Polymer takes
advantage of something
called Web Components
where each piece of the UI
is a separate component with
isolated responsibility.
It allows us to think
about our front end
in much the same way we think
about our microservices back
end architecture.
SERGIO FELIX: Here's an example.
This is the navigation bar
or the side bar for Louhi,
and you can clearly
see how it's composed
of tiny pieces of components
that interact together
to create a single-page
application.
We encourage
everyone to go check
out the Polymer Project
and the [? lead ?] project.
They're pretty interesting.
We found it useful.
So anyway, now we have an idea
of how to speed our services.
We've picked that technology.
And now we want to
be able to expose
these services to our clients--
our front ends or
their applications.
I'm going to talk about two
patterns you could use--
gateways and aggregator
or composite services.
Now gateways, as the name
implies, they act as a door.
They basically
decouple your clients
from your downstream services.
Gateways that basically allow
you to configure an optimal
API for each of your clients.
It also allows you to aggregate
calls to the services.
So your front end
doesn't need to know
that in order to get a flow, it
needs to go to three services.
The gateway can handle
that for the client.
Also, the gateway allows you
to set up throttling rules
and retry logic.
So if a service is
down for a moment,
the gateway can retry
a couple of times,
and then the user
doesn't even know.
This is also a good place
to place perimeter security.
This allows you to
block certain users
to access any of your
downstream services
that you might not want to.
And notice just that
perimeter security should not
be the only security that
you add to your application.
So how do we get a gateway in
the Springboard application?
You basically just
add this dependency,
and you're able to now match
routes, write predicates
and filters, and set up a bunch
of things, which is really,
really fast and magical.
And there's this other
thing called aggregator
or composite services.
These are basically just
services that aggregate
calls to other services.
This allows you
to maybe simplify
calls or implement things like
retry or get separate handling.
As an example, I told
you at the beginning
about this concept
of a flow in Louhi
that has notification
triggers in the pipeline.
And so instead of having
the front end talking
to these three services
to create just one flow,
we created an
aggregating services
called the flow service.
So now the front end can just
talk to the flow service,
and the flow service
handles logic
of talking to these other
services for the front end.
It also notices if a
service is down and maybe
do a couple of
retries if something
didn't happen as we expected.
Speaking of retries,
how do I even
configure the number of
retries in my service?
So when we were developing
our services in Louhi,
we had a bunch of
configuration that we
wanted to add to our services--
retries, time outs,
feature flags.
And we didn't want to redeploy
our whole service when we
changed one of these variables.
Well, turns out that the
Spring Cloud Kubernetes project
allows us to basically push a
configuration map to our GKE
cluster.
And as the cluster
notices these changes,
it delegates that
over to the services.
And then you can just read
these as variables annotated
with the add value annotation
in your application--
really, really convenient
for toggling features.
SOEREN WALLS: Since
GlassPane doesn't use Spring,
we didn't have this cool
configuration management
right out of the box.
So we decided to implement
this functionality ourselves.
We created this
configuration microservice
that listens for changes
to a [? protobuf ?]
file, essentially
sitting somewhere
in a repository containing the
configuration settings for all
of our microservices
like feature flags
and a number of retries and the
things Sergio was mentioning.
When this configuration service
detects a change to this file,
it sends a message via
Cloud Pub/Sub to all
of the other GlassPane
microservices to tell them,
hey, the configuration
is updated.
And they know to update
those values without having
to be redeployed.
SERGIO FELIX: OK so we
get a bunch of services up
and running, and
we might want to be
able to carry out complex
transactions across them.
Let me set an example.
Imagine this.
Imagine that you have
a project in Louhi,
and a project might have
additional metadata associated
with it.
And [? let's ?] pretend that a
user wants to delete a project.
So the project service gets a
message to delete project X.
So the product service
is really easy.
It just goes to its data
store and deletes the project,
and that's it.
There might be some
cleanup that needs
to happen from other services
if you deleted a project.
Maybe you stopped the
triggers or if it's
a pipeline that's
currently running,
stop it or something like that.
And you want to be able to
do these atomically as well.
And then on top of that,
imagine that in the future,
the system grows.
And there's new services
that are available,
and they also need to
react to things that happen
when a project gets deleted.
How do you do that?
It turns out that there are some
patterns called saga patterns.
I'll talk about orchestration
and choreography.
In orchestration, you
have a single service that
coordinates what's happening.
These coordinators
service makes sure
that things happen
in a certain order
or that they're even
happening at all.
The problem with
orchestration, though,
is if this magical
coordinator service somehow
dies, the other services
don't know what to do.
And so then you
have choreography.
In choreography, services
basically produce and listen
to events and then
react accordingly.
There is no single service
coordinating the actions.
The downside to this is that
there might be some overhead
because you're sending
events, and all the messages
have to get them.
But in Louhi, we use
a combination of both.
For the example that I
was just talking about,
the project service emits
an event saying, hey,
project X has been deleted.
And through eventual
consistency,
the message arrives
eventually to all the services
who are interested
in this message
and then delete the project
in a fan out strategy.
The opposite can also be done.
A single service might be
listening to multiple events
from other services.
For example, we want to do this
with our metric service we.
Want to use a metric service
to calculate release velocity
and additional metrics
in our application.
SOEREN WALLS: Sergio
covered some useful patterns
for coordinating your services.
But as your application
grows and you're maybe
using these aggregator
or composite services,
how do you keep track
of the requests that
are being sent between all
of these different services?
Distributed tracing is a
technique to do exactly this.
Zipkin is an example
of a tool that Spring
uses to add essentially
breadcrumbs to the HTTP headers
automatically to
all your requests,
allowing you to
track them as they
bounce from service to service.
This means that you can
troubleshoot errors and gather
metrics about the way that your
services are communicating--
really useful stuff.
As an alternative, there's
tools like Envoy and Istio
that create a service
mesh to enhance
HTTP requests between services
running on any tech stack
to provide your application
with distributed tracing
capabilities automatically.
SERGIO FELIX: So,
for Louhi, in order
to implement distributed
tracing we only
had to add these two
dependencies to our services
after this our Springboard
applications began pushing
information to Stackdriver.
That meant that we
can then go back
to our Stackdriver
in our GCP console,
and we could actually
tell and see the messages
bouncing across
all our services.
And if you wanted
to, you can even
click a button to go into
detail about what's happening
in each individual service.
How did the services
even find each other?
If I create a new
service, how do the others
know that it even exists?
Through this thing called
service discoverability.
It's been around for
a while, but it really
became popular for microservices
when Netflix introduced Eureka.
The concept is
actually pretty simple.
You have something called
a service registry.
When new services arrive, they
talk to the service registry
and say, hey, I'm the service.
I'm the product service.
And then other services can
query the service registry
to find out what other
services are available.
And you can do some really
interesting things with this.
I'll show an example here.
In Louhi, we had this general
trigger service and maybe
some implementations, a manual
trigger and a git trigger.
And we wanted to have
a way to enhance Louhi
to have new types of triggers
without actually going
back and changing the
existing source code.
In order to do this,
we leveraged server
discoverability.
If you wanted to add
maybe a Pub/Sub trigger,
we just wrote the
Pub/Sub trigger in a way,
drop it into the
cluster, the service
register with
Kubernetes, and then
the trigger service became
aware that this service actually
existed now.
With that, the
trigger service can
go back to the Pub/Sub trigger
and interrogate the server
the service asking what it did.
And then it could expose
that functionality
across the other services.
But what if a service goes down?
Unlike monolithic apps, one
major benefit of microservices
is that your whole
application can somewhat
be up and running even when one
of those services goes down.
How do you handle this?
I'll talk about some
patterns, behavior patterns,
circuit breaker patterns,
and self-healing services.
So a circuit breaker
pattern is basically
a pattern used to
detect failures
and allows your services
to react to those failures.
Here's an example.
Imagine that a user
wants to do something
with the flow service.
And in order for that to
happen, the flow service
needs to talk to
the trigger service.
If everything is
fine, the flow service
talks to the trigger
service, and that's it.
Imagine that for some reason,
the trigger services down.
The user doesn't know that
the trigger service is down,
obviously, and so
maybe the user will
click a button to try again.
Maybe the user's impatient
and clicks the button again
and again and again.
And then you run into this
issue where the flow service
has a bunch of open connections
waiting for the trigger servers
to come back.
And then the trigger
service is dead.
And so if it ever
becomes available again,
it doesn't know all
those other requests,
which are in progress.
And the user is super
confused because the user
doesn't know what's happening.
So here is the same thing
but with a circuit breaker.
Again, if nothing's
wrong, the flow service
through the breaker goes
to the trigger service.
Everything's fine.
The [INAUDIBLE] end,
and the user's happy.
But again, let's say that
the trigger service is down
for some reason.
The flow service goes
through the circuit breaker
onto the trigger service,
and now the circuit breaker
will try a couple of
times for you, depending
on how you've configured this.
When the circuit
breaker determines
that the trigger
service is unhealthy,
it will get a chance to react.
The circuit is open, and
now the circuit breaker
can actually throw out an
exception in your flow service.
And now, your fellow
service can handle logic.
Should you maybe tell the
user that something's wrong?
Maybe it'll store the request
and try again after the trigger
service becomes available.
SOEREN WALLS: So Sergio
threw the pattern at you.
Now when I show you how can
you actually implement this.
So we did this in
GlassPane, and here's how.
We had this metric
service in Java
that attempts to get all the
available metrics in GlassPane
by sending a request to
the metric microservice.
But what happens if that fails?
Well, as you can see here,
it just throws an exception,
and the user doesn't
know what happened.
Where are my metrics?
Well, we implemented
this by creating
a new annotation called the
method retry annotation.
As you can see, it takes
in a number of attempts
to attempt the method and
even a fallback method
so that when that number
of attempts is surpassed,
it actually can fall
back and say, hey,
we weren't able
to get a request.
But here we're going to pull
the metrics from the local
repository in this service--
maybe from previous requests--
and get some default
metrics to show the user.
And maybe we also show an
error message on the UI.
This is just one way you
can implement this pattern,
but this is the kind
of cool flexibility
that's possible
with microservices.
Depending on your
tech stack, this
might be provided automatically,
or you can create it yourself.
SERGIO FELIX: And then
there's this other thing
call self-healing services.
For example, Kubernetes
is able to monitor
the state or your health of
your application to find out
if it's down or not.
And if it is, Kubernetes
able to kill the plot
and create a new instance
of your applications
so that it makes sure that
is always up and running.
However, for this
to work, you need
to have a way for your
application to tell Kubernetes
that it's actually alive.
And in Springbopard
applications,
you can actually use this
Spring Starter Actuator.
The actuator basically adds
additional endpoints to report
the health of your application.
And if configured
correctly, you can even
use something called
micrometer to gather metrics
about traffic coming back
and forth in your service.
Also, I didn't want
to leave you hanging.
You can also use circuit
breaker pattern and service
discoverability in Spring.
You basically have [? fame ?]
clients that you use.
Notice that I don't
have an IP address.
You just basically name what
client you want to talk to,
and it goes back to
the service registry
and finds out who's the service
is, where it lives, and so on.
SOEREN WALLS: All
right, it sounds
like there's some cool
benefits to microservices,
but having all of these
different binaries
sounds toilsome.
How do you manage
all of this stuff?
Building, testing, and
deploying all of these services
can sound like a
big, daunting task--
maybe as big as a
monolithic app itself.
How do you manage
these services?
Automation is your friend.
There are tools out
there that we really
encourage you to
use that will help
to automate the different parts
of managing your services.
This can be in a CI/CD
pipeline to make it
so that you're deploying,
testing continuously
and automatically.
If you're trying to
do all this manually,
it's not going to be feasible.
SERGIO FELIX: So, those
things that we clearly
didn't cover in
this presentation
but we encourage you to go
out and search for this.
As Soeren mentioned,
you want to be
able to automate the creation
of your infrastructure--
either through code
or configuration.
There are lots of
tools out there
like Ansible, Puppet, Chef.
Google Cloud and Amazon
have implementations
for these things.
In Louhi, we use something
called Terraform.
You want to have a CI/CD
pipeline for microservice.
Make sure that you
always run test
whenever a change gets pushed
to one of your repositories.
Have a rollout
strategy-- you think
about how you're going to
deploy the services, how
you want to deploy them.
Always when the test passes, are
you're going to have a cannery?
Are you going to do
green blue deployments?
Think about that.
Set up error logging
metrics and reporting--
you want to do this
at the beginning
when you're developing
the services instead
of waiting until the end.
Obviously, don't forget
about security and testing.
We didn't cover
this topic at all,
but we encourage you
to go out and look.
SOEREN WALLS: So what
can you take away
from this presentation?
Well, earlier, we talked
about some of the pros
and cons of monolithic apps
versus microservices and how
microservices came to be.
We told you why we initially
built Louhi and GlassPane
as monolithic apps
and why we decided
to go and push into this great
adventure of converting them
into microservices, despite
the great refactoring costs.
Microservices allowed us to
iterate quickly and focus
on solving our users' needs.
So ultimately, we got
out of it what we wanted.
SERGIO FELIX: Throughout
this presentation,
we also showed you
how to take advantage
of existing patterns like
the strangled pattern
to slowly break
down your service.
We also talked
about cycle patterns
to reinforce atomic operations,
circuit breaker when something
goes down.
We used examples of
Louhi and GlassPane
to show you how
you can implement
the same patterns with
different technology stacks.
SOEREN WALLS:
Ultimately, there's
no one size fits all approach
to the perfect application.
If there were, we
wouldn't be here.
There would be no
point for us to talk.
But we hope that you
learned from our experience
with Louhi and GlassPane
and that you took away
some useful tips for how to
choose a good architecture
for your app.
We hope the road ahead
is a little clearer now.
There's this cool
search engine you
can use to search for all the
tools and things that we talked
about in this presentation
in case anything is vague.
But we wish you the best
of luck on your journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]